all right let's move on to a debate club
what's good Brendon was good Theo
Jeremy will it I mean Easter Bunny here
from writing PA and I got the bait club
Easter or Halloween both are candy
oriented which one's better gang gangs
buzz buzz
hop hop oriented let's go to chin what
do you think chin take it to the far
east bro and give this guy the answer
that he wants or Gant Easter what do you
say Easter a Halloween Easter Halloween
yeah that's a tough one I prefer
Halloween though
yeah I'm sound like the toughest
decision for a [ __ ] of all time I don't
know man not at all
Halloween [ __ ] trumps the [ __ ] out of
Easter Easter suckin fake zombie Jesus
day is anybody buying that [ __ ]
oh no it's a shame bro here's what I'm
saying is that Easter I think is just
Halloween for people that are afraid of
[ __ ] die bruh you know afraid of
[ __ ] well at least there's Halloween
but in the day in it yeah dress up like
bunnies yeah Easter is just kind of a
daytime Halloween it's for it's more for
children and it's more for Jesus Christ
dude it's more for Mortensen
yeah the Lord and Savior bro he you know
he came back you got to celebrate it
it's more of like a family holiday
Halloween is like dark yeah Halloween if
you kill somebody you can blame on
Halloween if you steal something you
know if you don't want to see if you
want to leave your family also house way
better because girls it gives them a
reason dressed up like [ __ ] ain't no
girl Ginter tits out on the easter day
man did you go to the right church bro
yeah because church girls are wild man
church girls are why yeah but they can't
get them [ __ ] sweater puppies out in
the church but they wrap them up dog and
that's even hotter out there you write
little mystery oh he seems better yeah
they start sweating picture of a big
cross on her neck dude
yeah all right you're right white thighs
hanging out bra or black or black white
or black guys hanging out or even I feel
like a laborer fun than white church
it's very OB yeah somebody dies every
time I black Church - I feel like
they'll just son of the must be carrying
somebody through the lucky Ernie's dead
yeah bring it right back and they're
clearly acting dude yeah black church is
definitely way worth waiting but I think
it's just the same it goes across the
board for like I think black people just
in general have more they just have more
exciting there's just more of like a
energy that's fun yeah just more of it
just like so uptight
there's not more there's more wild
energy you know there's more of a free
there's more freelance energy more fun
yeah there's more fun energy you got a
black church do black funeral [ __ ] it's
fun do you want to die at a black frame
you're like damn this [ __ ] is hype DJ
yeah this is powerful wind stop yes we'd
stop at a nice one yeah got a good one
yeah dude that's true brah and here's
your family right here I'm Brendan
that's my stepmom Youngjae job there
damn which one will have to write on the
right that's longneck job on the right
Wow look at that [ __ ] reach piece on
him uh oh my god he probably got to see
whatever he wants my dad looks like the
ruler of Iraq that's a great Iranian huh
he does what is he white you guys are so
tan lion I'm the only tan one dude you
definitely have a little bit of that
[ __ ] debt you got a little more beige
in your bra no I feel you I'm the
darkest of my family yeah you dad very
much does a very desert e-type of yes
you know I'm sure mine oh you reminds me
a little bit also of machete Tom Sally
but also of machete who is that guy
Michelle
nor tre oh yeah it's kind of offensive
because that's an ugly man but yeah
alright any Trejo dude he did small too
but we did crime he started a taco shop
it sounds like try to go ahead and donut
shop no my bad he's been 7000 movies
yeah
damn bro uh he's getting that church
girl cross on to he was great in the
dusk till dawn yeah I'm gonna go oh I
love that movie Easter or Halloween
Halloween all goddamn day that's an easy
one Halloween's fun Easter is a bummer
it's taken our culture corner uh all
right let's see you the culture think Oh
Halloween all day I love Halloween me
too love Halloween night before
Christmas Halloween movies okay I'd like
an [ __ ]
Halloween oh yeah yeah but Halloween you
also can like you know buddy get a drunk
on Easter unless you got a [ __ ] up
yeah no yeah that's true people aren't
getting that drunk on Easter
but horror movies Halloween you can be
left out of Halloween I feel like like
if you don't plan ahead you don't get a
costume and somebody doesn't invite you
out to the [ __ ] then you're just at home
[ __ ] looking at like a thing a little
kind of face pain or something
you [ __ ] lonely and [ __ ] let's make
up whatever costume you want yam I think
you know in order to go you're just
wandering the streets you know dressed
up like Raggedy Andy what do you do on
these day but on Easter you'll have your
family it's a family day really that's
true that's true that's a good point
you'd be left out of killing your family
I just like there's more stuff to get
invited to I don't know man it's a tough
one what do you got your shirt it sound
of you should be dressed up in it I
don't think about holidays no holidays
well it sounds like an exciting
existence talk about sitting lowly with
face paint I'm happy
but at least I'm celebrating it though
dude oh you had a better time than you
least I showed up at least I'm not the
one looking at his window really man
look at that sad [ __ ] [ __ ]
singing hate comments when you could be
out there with that sad [ __ ]
dogs it could be too sad [ __ ]
if you come out and join me bro you know
all right if you invited me maybe okay
you're right you're right so I think it
runs both ways uh I'm out
[Music]